[Música]
en el inicio de la segunda semana de la
Cumbre climática de la ONU en Egipto hay
frustración entre los negociadores que
deben resolver los detalles para llegar
a un acuerdo antes del cierre programado
para este viernes las promesas incluyen
hacer recortes drásticos en las
emisiones que contribuyen al
calentamiento global dentro de esta
década y contribuir a los cientos de
miles de millones de dólares que
necesitan cada año Las Naciones en
desarrollo que ya luchan para hacer
frente a los impactos del cambio
climático para un balance de lo que fue
la primera semana y lo que se podría
lograr en esta que comienza conectamos
con cara en oliveira ella es directora
de asuntos externos de nature conservas
y Brasil Karen gracias a ustedes y la
conferencia empezó con la inclusión en
la agenda de la idea de crear este
mecanismo de financiación para pérdidas
y daños un término que se refiere a los
costos materiales e inmateriales de los
impactos del cambio climático que no
pueden ser evitados se logrará algún
avance o será solamente una discusión
simbólica
pero adelante Ah mira este es un punto
muy importante porque incluso esta
galería de fotos que acaba de presentar
Jesús mucho lo que estamos hablando acá
este tema de pérdida de daños siempre
estuve en el acuerdo en el documento de
la conferencia pero por la primera vez
se empezó de verdad a discutir cómo será
posible Tener dinero tener un dinero
adicional no O que está ya programado
pero un dinero nuevo que pueda
Efectivamente es rápidamente ayudar las
los países más vulnerables y aquellos
otros que también está enfrentando
tantas urgencias tantas necesidades
climáticas como Podemos
mirar en esta galería de fotos que acaba
presentar entonces las negociaciones
para este tema están
en torno de discutir como este dinero
nuevo podrás llegar además también de
todo un mecanismo de cómo se puede medir
Cómo se puede cuantificar Cómo se puede
reportar y para quién es este resultado
entonces este sin duda alguna es de los
puntos claves de esta conferencia
no es una conferencia de grandes
unidades pero es una es una conferencia
donde se busca decir cómo hacer pues son
los instrumentos que tenemos para hacer
bien Y a cuánto cuesta hacer este es el
objetivo principal en este momento
en esta Cumbre precisamente sobre el
tema de pérdidas y daños los discursos
de representantes de los países más
contaminantes cada vez digamos que han
incluido un mayor reconocimiento a la
vulnerabilidad de los países que ya ven
los efectos del cambio climático sin ser
los más responsables sin embargo Cuando
llega la hora de compensar Y de
responsabilizar lo que se ve es que los
países desarrollados están presentando
un bloqueo y no se sabe si va a ser
posible llegar a hacer posible este
documento Usted qué opina
es que un punto clave porque de un modo
general todos se conocen la urgencia
climática en la necesidad de un
enfrentamiento a todas estas técnicas
necesarios Pero hay mucha cautela hay
mucho cuidado de cómo será puesto este
viñedo nuevo Y esto no solo para países
que están con con más situación de
desarrollo más avanzado una situación de
país desarrollado también observamos
listo en China o también en Brasil
porque en este momento también tiene
grandes emisiones y si no asumen un
compromiso real y efectivo de reducir
drásticamente sus emisiones
también serán responsables por todo ese
impacto que está
llevando más prejuicio a a los países
menos menos favorecidos a los países más
vulnerables entonces no es solo una
cuestión de los países desarrollados
según la cuestión de los países que hoy
son grandes emisores y esto es que
emiten mucho gas verdadero son los
grandes responsables por la mayor parte
de las pérdidas globalmente Karen en
esta completa el momento ha habido una
marcadísima ausencia de líderes
latinoamericanos Qué mensaje lanza esto
y Qué consecuencias Podría tener en la
región
es muy importante la participación de
todos y tener la voz de todos incluso
para la parte de los bosques tenemos que
destacar el anuncio del presidente de
Colombia que buscó justamente anunciar
la posibilidad de ver de los bosques de
los países amazónicos para el próximo
año para que se pueda trabajar en grupo
y así de un modo más fuerte a colocar
posiciones que pueda hacer este cambio y
damas conciencia y más practicidad a
este resultado entonces
la participación de Colombia y todo que
está presentando para intentar hacer
frente a todos estos grandes grandes
desafíos que están acá pero de un modo
general
necesitamos de más presencia
latinoamericana y trabajar juntos una
integridad mayor principalmente de los
bosques amazónicos donde hoy Tenemos
muchos problemas con la deforestación
con la pérdida de la cobertura vegetal y
ejecutado en en este sentido acabamos
llegando a emisiones muy significativas
Entonces estos países latinoamericanos
que están en los Vázquez amazónicos
puede trabajar conjuntamente será una
consola importante quizá incluso retomar
otros otros antiguos a aspectos de las
negociaciones como el tratado de
cooperación amazónica o incluso el pacto
de Leticia Estos son puntos para hacer
discutir bastante principalmente ahora
que llega acá a conferencia también a el
gobierno electo de Brasil nula que
también tenemos a expectativa que pueda
mantener un diálogo muy fuerte y
propicio para para esta enfrentamiento
al cambio climático en toda América
Latina